Hello
最近我身邊的人都對這個AI Agent挺好奇的
然後甚至有人花了幾千塊錢去買課啊之類的
然後也有朋友問我究竟怎麼要使用AI Agent啊之類的
之类的
然后所以我觉得我可以稍微分享一下
我是怎么使用的
就是作为一个普普通通的程序员
我是怎么样用AI agent的
其实我真正用AI agent也是从OpenClaw
火了之后
我才真正开始搭自己的AI agent
嗯
其实作为普通人
把agent用起来是很快的
而且只需要给agent一些基础的能力
很基础的能力
他就能够帮你提升不少效率
这是我这么感觉的
然后呢这期视频不是一个教程
他只是
我只是想要通过这个视频讲一下我是怎么使用的
然后另外
假如你看到这么一坨黑黑的东西
你很
表示很慌
不知道这是什么东西
你也不知道这是什么东西
你也不知道这个命令行
你也不知道命令行
又或者你还没有
那这期视频可能
就不是
你可能会看得有点懵
不过也无所谓
大概你了解一下
这个概念也OK
OK
所以呢
就是这样的
我一般
其实现在AI agent
我认为啊
就是
比较主流的
就三个
就是说
当然AI agent有很多类型
例如腾讯的Workbody
或者Manus
那是另外一类AI agent
甚至Claw Desktop
他们是另外一类
就是有完整的交互界面的AI agent
但是我今天聊的呢
或者是我平时使用的呢
是没有的
没有交互界面的
它不是腾讯Workbody那种
它
我先把那个
先翻一下墙
然后
然后现在主流的我认为就三个
一个就是claw对吧
也是claw
然后呢一个是products
skip先不更新
然后呢还有一个就是opencode
其实就是这三个
我觉得
但你用任何一个是没有任何关系的
唯一的影响是什么呢
Claw
大家都知道
可能都听过
它很容易封号
所以它也不太容易
在国内不是那么容易能够订阅的了
然后Codex呢
稍微好一点
但它也是个国外的模型
然后你要买它
可能稍微也是麻烦一点
然后至于OpenCode是什么呢
open code就是一个你可以接任何大模型
基本像国产的那种
质谱
minimax
kimia
deepstick
都可以
当然
像这些大模型他们也提供了claw code
适配的
endpoint
的
那个接口
甚至是codex适配的接口
但都ok
所以而且这是其实没有太大关系的
就是如果你不是用它来写代码
这个问题其实不大的
然后呢
OK这是第一个前提
就是你要有这么一个东西
在你的命令行里面启动
然后第二个东西呢
就是你需要有一个稳定的地方
存一些东西
然后这个东西可能是你的
一些
这就很个人化了
就例如
在这里我放了user.md
然后列了一些我的主要目标
然后我是一个什么人
我现在处于一个什么状态
但可能你不需要这些
然后还有就是
我的
那个股票持仓
就例如你想让你的agent做什么
你想他成为一个什么样的agent
你就给他什么样的讯息就好了
然后还有我用我的agent来管理我的代办事项
所以我还有一个todo
然后另外呢
还有一个叫bring dumb的一个文件夹
里面放了
很多我让我的agent去记录一些我稍重机事的一些想法
然后还有一些
还有那个像什么美国签证材料
就这种各种东西
然后还有一些调研的报告啊什么的
然后就是像我让这个agent帮我去做一些什么研究
然后我让他把这东西存起来
就这么一个地方
ok 这是第二点了
就是说你要有一个地方让他存东西
然后第三点就是你让这个agent有联网的能力
然后这个联网的能力呢不是说简单的
就是他可以用他可以网上搜点东西
而是说让它能够使用你的浏览器就OK了
我举个例子
就是我现在用任求一个都无所谓
那我就用claw code吧
把它关掉
claw code例如我跟大家说
我一般喜欢用语音转文字
我就跟他说
去小红书搜一下
看现在美国签证
免面签续签
有什么注意事项
还有什么坑
是大家遇到的
然后当然现在其实包括
包括那个小红书自己也有他的AI
你也不一定要这样去问你的agent
我只做一个演示
就是告诉你agent有联网的能力
他可以帮你去搜寻东西
并且归纳总结东西
然后他就像
他在用我的那个brave浏览器
我先打开看一下
OK然后这是
这应该是他的操作
我是没有做任何操作的
然后
他说找到了164个bc
然后各种
哦他没法点开这个页面
可能是被小文书给拦截了
然后他说哦
直接访问这个url是不行的
然后他会怎么做呢
他可能会换一种方法去做
因为他需要看笔记内容嘛
对吧
这个可能需要的时间会久一点
哦他终于看到了
刚才一闪而过了
他已经看完并把那个笔记给关掉了
嗯
ok 然後你可以看到左上角這裡
他又看了下一篇文章
他一直在看新文章
然后你看
你再看
然后这就是他在代替你做调研
然后
嗯
这个其实我们有时候用那个
什么
deep seek啊
或者是豆包啊
他有联网能力
对不对
但是
作为你的个人AI agent
活在你的电脑里面呢
他有一个优势
是他可以使用你真实浏览器去访问东西
并且他有登录状态
他有我的登录状态
那这样子像小红书
像X
或者像类似的一些其他的封闭的网站
他也可以去访问
而且没那么容易被触发那个反爬虫
并且
OK
他把他已经做完调研了
然后他自动把这个
云南窗口给关掉了
OK
然后这就是他的一些结论
然后一些坑
blah blah blah
材料
只带几样多交反而坏事
大家踩过具体的坑
照片不能和护照上的一样
然后OK就是这样
然后甚至最后他说
他建议要不要把这些细节都放在我那个笔记里面
因为其实我之前就已经有跟他在聊过这个事情
甚至当时我填那个签证事情表的时候呢
我有很多东西不懂
我是一边跟他在聊一边去填
一边他网上搜资料一边教我怎么做
所以我们之前已经有过一些积累了
然后他现在建议要不要把这些新的坑也写进去
其实就这样
在我看来
你只需要给这两个能力给agent
第一个
就是给他一个稳定的可以存东西的地方
让他每次开启新绘画
他都能够稳定的抓取
第二点
就是给他联网的能力
就已经能够帮你做很多事情了
帮你做调研啊
然后去例如归纳总结你的那个
例如他可以根据你的账
你的持仓
你买了什么股票
每天可以去
那个财经网站上
帮你去搜集相关的资讯
类似这样
然后再具体说一下
刚才的那个联网能力呢
是这个webassets这个skill做到的
我一般喜欢在我这个当前目录下
叫opencodeagent这个项目下
去运行我的agent
是因为我把所有的skill都塞到这里面来
我方便我管理并且去修改这样
这些全都是skill
就是我一般会用到的skill
刚才联网的用到的是
是webassets是这个skill
就他会调用我的浏览器
其实我平时用的不是brave浏览器
brave是给agent用的
我自己用的是chrome
我可以说
我可以跟agent说
然后现在我就可以把这个tab给关掉了
我一般就用到
就是200
就20万
剩下文我基本就不用了
就现在用的是64,000
我就基本就把它关掉
算了看个新的吧
然后我就可以说
控制我的日常浏览器
打开谷歌
调研一下
人体工学升降桌
大家对这个东西什么看法
好像不这样吧
控制我的日常浏览器
甚至不要打碍谷歌了
就让他自己去做调研
然后他就加载了刚才那个web access这个skill
然后在那之前大家找一个叫research的skill
然后他现在需要用我主力浏览器
我的日常浏览器
所以呢
他需要我同意权限
我同意
然后可以看到这里
他已经左下角
这里他已经打开了一个标签
去做研究了
嗯
然后他说我在reddit上面找到一些讨论
然后他就你看这就是他打开的
然后他也不会影响我进行操作
例如我还停留在这个页面的话
他是会自己在做这些事情
然后是
oh no
是我自己点的
应该对他会自己做自己的事情
然后
就是这样子
嗯
其實我是想要做一期稍微小白一點的視頻的
但是我知道其實就算是這樣
可能也會有門檻
嗯
不過可能假如這個東西有人看的話
我接下來會再做一期更小白的
或者是更深入的視頻
先這樣吧
拜拜